une traînée noir telle une interminable
cicatrices l'échouage du raki japonais m
v oix cacho le 25 juillet dernier mais
l'île maurice à rude épreuve
si l'essentiel des 4000 tonnes
d'hydrocarbures que transportait le
navire ont été pompés cette semaine il
reste toujours 90 tonnes de fuel à bord
les mètres cubes de carburant qui risque
très fortement de se répandre dans la
mer après la scission en deux une à vide
le premier ministre du pays praveen
d'ubs notent à d'ores et déjà annoncé
pour des réclamations dédommagement
allait être formulée les propriétaires
du bateau ont présenté des excuses
il ya eu et il n'y a qu'en encore
toujours des dommages qui ont été causés
que ce soit hollande à l'environnement à
aux professionnels pêcheurs plaisanciers
et autres et bien sûr à cette pratique
de l'apei donc là aussi il faut l'aide
de certains experts au pouvoir nous
guider et pour faire des réclamations
est vraiment eu l il ya une partie des
réparations qui vont se faire déjà et
puis d'autres qui vont suivre
après des propos qui ne doivent pas
faire oublier que le risque de marée
noire semble définitivement écarté
lorsque les hydrocarbures n'ont pu être
comblées
ils ont été contenus
notamment grâce à la détermination de la
population mauricienne
une mobilisation qui sonne comme une
évidence pour les insulaires parce que
on se sent vraiment concerné on nous
habitons ici
voilà nous sommes nés ici c'est le
gagne-pain de plusieurs personnes des
bateliers centre de plongée entre autres
et voila c cnet beauté ce matin c'est
notre richesse c'est notre essai notre
maison c'est notre patrimoine c'est gras
c'est grâce à ça que beaucoup de
mauriciens et vive et ça fait partie de
notre quotidien voire de protéger notre
notre territoire et donc l'impôt temps
là s'est produit hollywoodien envoyer
les boudins chercher le matériel pour
pouvoir produire les boudins justement
et puis aider les pêcheurs les plongeurs
qui vont aller placer en mer une aide a
également été fournies par la france qui
a dépêché sur place en fin de semaine
dernière un bâtiment de soutien et
d'assistance
outre mer ainsi qu'un avion militaire
transportant une vingtaine de tonnes de
matériel
coupler des efforts mauricien et
français ont permis de pomper la majeure
partie des hydrocarbures entre 800 et
1000 tonnes de fuel se sont néanmoins
déversés dans la nature dont une partie
sur les plages paradisiaques de cette
île de l'océan indien
un accident qui aura des conséquences à
la fois écologiques sanitaires et
économiques la pêche et le tourisme aux
représentants de secteurs majeurs pour
l'archipel